all right hey everyone welcome back
this is people who gave me okay alright
so if as usually you can take a second
to
your su ID so we know who is here um
so today's lecture will be a
choose-your-own-adventure
lecture so I think you know by now
you've learned a lot about the technical
aspects of building learning algorithms
and then in the third course in the
third set of modules you saw some of the
principles for debugging learning
algorithms and how that you use these
tools in order to be efficient in how
you build a machine learning application
what I want to do today is step through
with you a moderately complicated
machine learning application and
throughout all of today's lecture I'm
gonna you know step you through a
scenario and then ask you to kind of
choose your own adventure because if
you're working on this project what are
you gonna do right and so you give you
all that practice in the Nix
what are in a bit that we have on
thinking through machine learning
strategy and you know I've seen in so
many projects there they're sometimes
things that a less strategically
sophisticated team will take a year to
do but if you're actually very strategic
and very sophisticated in deciding what
you will do Nix right how they drive a
project forward I've seen many times
that what a different team will take to
do maybe you could do it in a month or
two and you know if you are trying to I
don't know where the research paper or
build a business or the product the the
the ability to drive a machine learning
project quickly gives you a huge
advantage and just you know you're
making much more efficient use your life
as well right um so in for today I'd
like to I'm gonna host a scenario post a
machine learning application and say
alright
I mean you are the CEO of this project
what are you gonna do next so but I'd
like to have today's meeting be quite
interactive as well so can I get people
to sit in groups of two in ideally three
or so maybe plus minus one and tried
sit next to someone that you don't work
with all the time so if it's simply
sitting makes your best friend I'm glad
your best friend is in the class with
you but go sit with someone else because
I think I'm I've done this multiple
times in the discussions that he Richard
you talk to someone that you don't know
super well so actually take a second
introduce yourself and just be cool
neighbor i yes
so the example I want to go through
today is actually a continuation of the
example I described briefly in the last
lecture I taught building a speech
recognition system right so remember
briefly motivated this trigger word
awake word or trigger word detection
system last time where you know right
iiiiii have both an Amazon echo and a
Google home but you know is this a lot
of work to configure these things to
turn on and off your lightbulbs and so
if you can build a chip to sell to say a
lamp maker to recognize phrases like you
know let's say we call the lamp robin
then you can recognize phrases like
Robert turned on right Robert turn off
and you have a little switch to give
this thing different names you're called
robbers or later or elders or something
as you can also linear turn on later
turn off and give to give your lamp a
name and just say hey Robert turn on
right so rather than detecting different
names and turn on and turn off I'm just
gonna focus on just for the technical
discussion I'm just going to focus on
the phrase Robert turn on but this is
kind of the same problem you need to
solve like four times to give it two
names or to turn on and turn off so I'm
gonna abbreviate Robert turn on this RTO
right if you want to call your name
Robert and tell your lamp to turn on I
think I was inspired by well Isaac
Asimov wrote these own robotic novel C's
and and all his robots names started
with our so maybe our s robot turned on
and so let's see so let's say that you
are the new CEO of a small start-up with
you know three persons and your goal is
the building is to build a circuit or
actually your goal is to build a
learning algorithm that can recognize
this race Robert turned on so that when
someone either buys this lamp and they
say Robert turned on the lamp can turn
on right and just focusing on the task
of building a linen you know to be CEO
to start to be to do a lot of things
where I need to figure out how to do the
embedded circuitry you figure out
whether that Mika's sales general so
there's all that stuff but for today
let's just focus on the machine learning
aspect of it and so my first question to
you
it's very open-ended is but and this is
the life of a CEO right you wake up one
day and you just got to decide what to
do but so my first question to you is
the open-ended question is you're the
CEO
oh you're gonna show up at work you know
tomorrow in your startup office and you
want to build a learning algorithm to
detect the phrase Robert turn on for
this application right so um so my
question is what you're gonna do right
so take a take a minute to answer that
by yourself first no don't don't discuss
your neighbor yeah but then you're gonna
show up in your office and and then
you're gonna start working on this
engineering problem to build a neural
network to do this so and and do this as
yourself right don't don't don't pretend
that you have this hypothetical whatever
a start-up CEO with ten months ten
billion dollars to spend or whatever
just do this is let's say yeah I but I
don't think this is a terrible startup
idea is not the best idea but I think
this could work so you're actually
welcome to do this but let's say you
decide to do this and you go into your
office tomorrow like what do you do
right want you to take um why should
take let's say two minutes to enter an
answer then we can you can discuss I
think yeah yes one thing I really like
about answer is
the meat is extinguished share a pot
right in fact when you start a new
project and I think when you start a new
project like that assuming you've not
worked my trigger words detection before
you know reading research papers or
reading code on github or reading blog
posts on this problem is a very good way
to quickly level up your knowledge and I
think that you know it turns out that um
in terms of your exploration strategy
right um I want to describe to you how I
read research papers which is so this is
a not a good way to review the
literature which is if the x-axis is
time and the vertical axis is research
papers what some people will do is find
the first research paper and meet that
until it's done and then go and find a
second research paper and beat that
until it's done and then you can find
the third research paper in this very
sequential way of meeting research
papers and I find it the more strategic
way to go through these resources
everything ranging from blog posts lots
of good medium articles that explain
things write research papers write
github is if you use a parallel
exploration process where this is
actually what it feels like when I'm
doing research on the way I'm trying to
learn about the new field I'm not that
experienced right so I've she's done a
lot of work on trigger word detection
but if I hadn't worked on this before
then I would probably find you know
three papers so again x-axis is time and
Mercury axis is different papers and you
know read a few papers kind of in
parallel at a surface level and skim
them and based on that you might decide
to read that one in greater detail and
then to add other papers that you start
skimming and maybe find another one do
you want to read in great detail and
then to gradually add new papers it's
you're reading this and be some to
completion and some not to completion
you know I was actually chatting with um
one of my friends at Peter Bua former
students
at Berkeley who mentioned that he was
wanting to learn about a new topic and
he he was he told me is compiling a
reading list of 200 research papers they
want to read that sounds like a lot you
rarely read 200 papers but I think if
you read 10 papers you have a basic
understanding if you read 50 you're a
pretty decent understanding if you read
like 100 I think you're a very good
understanding of a few but often this is
time well spent
I guess oh and some other tips again
this is something I'm really thinking if
you really are CEO of this startup and
this is what you want to do what advice
would I give you when you're reading
papers other things to realize one is
that some papers don't make sense right
and this fine you know you might be some
papers I just go nope I don't think that
makes sense so and and it's not that
uncommon for us to find papers from a
decade ago then and we learned that half
of it was straight and the other half of
it you know was really talking about
things that were not that important
right so it's okay authors
you know usually papers are technically
accurate but often what they thought was
important like maybe an author thought
that using Vacheron was really important
than this problem but it just turns out
not to be the case that that happens a
lot but that happens sometimes and I
think the other tactic that I see
Stanford students sometimes not use
enough is talking to experts including
contacting the authors so when I read
the paper I don't I don't bother the
authors unless I've actually like tried
to figure it out myself
right but if you actually spend some
time trying to understand the paper and
if it really doesn't make sense to you
it's okay to email the authors and see
if they respond and and people are busy
maybe there's a 50% chance they respond
and that's okay because it takes you
five minutes to write an email and
there's a 50% chance to get back to you
that could be time pretty well spent
but but don't don't don't bother people
on this you try to do your homework I
should get a lot of emails from you know
high school students that do not feel
like they've done their own work and
right and then so so just don't don't
don't bother people unless you've
actually tried to do cool so after
looking at the literature and having a
base maybe downloading a open-source
implementation or getting a sense I've
been averaging when I try oh and it
turns out the trig reward detection
literature is actually one literature
where there isn't consensus on this is a
good algorithm is a bad algorithm right
despite all the trigger word a way core
detection system is that you know some
of you may use already there there there
isn't actually consensus in the research
for me today unlike this is the best
ever and to try but so let's say that um
you read some papers download some open
source of invitations and now you want
to start training your first system
right a lot of time we talked about this
we talked a little bit about how much
time you will spend to collect data and
then you know we said you spend a small
amount of time spent like a day or maybe
two days at most so collect your first
data set to start training up a model
but my next question to you is what data
would you collect right um in particular
what train death test data would you
collect so you've decided on an initial
neural network architecture and you want
to train something to recognize this
face robert turned on i think this
probably i don't think it's possible to
download the data set i don't think
anyone has collected the data set with
the worst rapper turned on and post it
down the internet so you have to collect
your own data for this particular
trigger for a so you want to use but
some you know sco of this sort of trying
to build a new net to detect the phrase
robert turned on what data do you
collect right so once you take once you
again take let's say three minutes to
write an answer to this yeah I think
this is an interesting
robber turned on over and over and then
data augmentation data augmentation is
one of those techniques that is a way to
reduce variance in your learning
algorithm because you're generating more
data and having worked on this problem
I happen to know data augmentation works
you know it's very useful for this
problem but if you didn't already know
that fact this is one of the things I
would probably not do right away because
I would train a quick and dirty system
validate that you really have a high
variance problem before investing of the
effort into data augmentation so they
don't know as well those techniques that
so you know like it never hurts they're
all very very hurt so usually helps but
I don't bother to make that investment
unless you have collected the evidence
that you actually have a high variance
problem and that this is actually a good
use of your time
yeah I think this is just one that she
just actually nice so require gonna
start to st. Robert turn a hundred times
so doing really nice thing about that
you can get done really quickly when I'm
working with teams I actually think in
terms of hours in terms of how long it
take us to do something so this one you
could probably do in like 30 minutes
right so you get your dataset collected
30 minutes ain't get going or if you run
around Stanford they just ask you no
friends or strangers to speak into your
laptop microphone you didn't spend a few
hours together much bigger data set then
possible to start up so I priority do
that I probably actually couldn't
collect data and several hours for app
didn't only spend 30 minutes but this is
actually pretty interesting as well
because unless you get it done pretty
quickly access right so um yeah so let
me actually uh share some more concrete
advice right and I think actually some
point some time back to prepare a
homework problem that you see later in
this course Ken and Eunice and I we're
actually you know building the system
partially to create the homework right
then you see later in this course this
is a good this trigger word thing is a
nice running example that we're using a
few points throughout this course um so
here's one thing you can do and this is
actually what what we did right which is
a collect oh well simplifying a little
bit collect a hundred examples of
ten-second audio clips right and so it
turns out once you grab a hold of
someone and ask them to speak into your
microphone you know you can keep them
for three seconds which is how long it
takes to say Robert turn on or you can
keep them for ten seconds which they're
actually very willing to spend that
extra seven seconds
you right but so if this is ten seconds
of audio data you know so this is ten
seconds of audio and and audio is just
patterns of little changes in air
pressure right so if you plot audio the
reason looks like this waveform it's
just the way you're hearing my voice
this yo my voice or the speakers are
creating very rapid changes in the air
pressure and your ear measures those
very rapid changes in the air pressure
interprets in sound and so a microphone
is a sensitive device for recording
these very very high frequency changes
in the air pressure and this plots that
you see an audio is just what is the air
pressure at different moments in time
right but so given a 10 second clip like
this if this is the 3 second section
where they said Robert turned on then
what you would like to do is to build a
nest Lam say they can sit here and the
lamp is turned off turn it off turn it
off turn off turn off turn off and at
the moment they finished saying Robert
turn on you know you turn it on so this
is a open table Y really right and then
and then it's not detecting afraid right
so so what you want to do for the trick
word system is at you know pretty much
the moment they finish saying Robert
turn on you want your learning algorithm
to output a 1 that's your target label
why I saying yep I just heard this
trigger word and for all other times you
want it to output 0 right because cuz
and then the 1 is when you decide to
turn on the lamp at that moment in time
right so to collect the data set here's
something you can do which is collect
100 audio clips of 10 seconds each and
you know when I'm prioritizing my work
home my teams work I would really you
know look at these numbers and think
okay let's say let's say you actually if
you are doing it let's say you are
running around Stan's
and you want to collect a hundred audio
clips maybe 10 people 10 clips per
person or maybe a hundred different
people
I would actually estimate you know if
you go to Stanford cafeteria how long
does it take to get one person right and
you can pray get one person every minute
or two if you go to a busy place them on
like a Stanford cafeteria so you can
pray to get this done in like a 100 to
200 minutes late or three hours right
it's not that bad so you get this done
quite quickly and so and lets you
collect 100 audio clips and actually for
them for the purposes of today let's say
you collect hundred or do clips to use
for training 25 for your dev set and
zero for the test set right it's
actually not that uncommon if you're
building a new product they just not
have a test set because you go is to
build something that you're convinced is
you know just early prototyping phases
of the project sometimes I don't bother
with my test set if you if it goes the
function paper then of course you need a
rigorously corrected test that but if
you're just building a product and you
don't need a rigorous evaluation
sometimes you can just get started
without doing with a test set right
those pretty little get started um and
then
[Applause]
all right so taking that audio clip from
above one thing you can do to turn this
into supervised learning problem is to
take so you know the phrase robber
turn-on can be said in less than three
seconds so let's say you take three
seconds as the duration of audio right
so what you can do is a clip out so
let's say here was when Robbie turn on
my set so what you can do is the type of
what you can do is then clip out
different audio clips of three seconds
so here's one audio clip you can take
that audio clip this is X and the target
label is zero because Robert turn-on was
not set and you can take I know this
audio clip a different random nature
clipped with three second clip and that
clip also as the toggle a buzz rope and
you know for this one right which is a
three second clip there come that that
that ends at the reel on the last part
of the on sound you would have a target
label of one right so and when you learn
about sequence models there are and ends
you learn a better method than this
explicit clipping but for now let's say
you take these on audio clips and turn
it into please so take a ten second clip
and by clipping around different windows
you can take your let's say 100 clips
and because for each 10 second clip you
can take different windows you could
turn this into let's say 3000
training examples right so here I took a
10-second clip and - and show you know
totally three different three-second
windows but if you take thirty three
second windows then each 10-second audio
clip becomes thirty examples and now
you've turned the problem into a binary
classification problem where you need to
train a neural network that inputs a
three second clip and they build it as
either 0 1 right those mean this and so
this is an example of the the more
complex pipelines you might have if
you're building a learning algorithm to
take a continuous you know audio
detection problem to turn into the
binary classification problem which
you've learned how to build barriers
near networks for right and again we
learn about our own ends you learn about
other ways to process sequence data or
temporal data okay so um go ahead oh is
this manual even yes I I would yeah
actually if you have a hundred examples
it's not that hard to just listen to it
you know on your laptop with some audio
playing software to figure out when when
they finish saying or Robert turn on and
then at that moment to put a 1 in the
target label because this is really when
you want the lamb to turn on right so
any other questions actually few fideos
clarifying questions yeah go ahead
oh I wonder if this is gonna cost a
problem that ones are tools bars
oh sure let me get back to that and
things
if there are specific reason we only
train them with three seconds
I see yeah why do we do three seconds
there for five seconds there's a yeah
because there's another hyper prompt you
can test so I can go oh no oh yeah you
have to stand really slowly to take
three seconds is this right reabsorb it
turn on right so okay this is a design
choice yeah um alright so so um let's
say you do this feed it to supervised
learning algorithm train a neural
network um and let's say that when you
classify this when you run this
algorithm you end up with 99.5% accuracy
right but you find that the algorithm
has zero detection right and you know
and what I mean is that whether audio
you give it it just outputs zero all the
time so the algorithm just says nope I
never heard the phrase Rob I turn on you
know so so so so and so my question to
you is you know and by the way the
reason I'm going through these scenarios
is um I found that a good way to gain
good intuitions and and to become good
at making these decisions is these are
the decisions that project leader right
a tech leader our CEO needs to make
these are actually like pretty much
exactly the decisions you need to make
and I find that um one of the ways to
gain this type of experience if you you
know find a job with a good AI team and
work with them for five years
right and then you said you lived
through this and you see what they do
but instead of needing you to go and
spend five years to see ten examples of
this I'm trying to step you through
maybe one example in
in one hour or so so instead of yo
gaining this experience to work
experience which is great but takes many
many he has how many many months hoping
to you know let's just put you in the
position of making these decisions you
can learn from that much faster right
but so and all the examples I'm giving
or actually completely realistic right
there you either exactly or very similar
to things I have seen in actual you know
very real project so question is uh your
learning algorithm gives sisters out 95%
ac0 dissections what do you do let me
mention some of some dances are really
light I think that you know I when I
think of building learning algorithms
the process is often specify a deaf set
and all test set that measure what you
care about and then you don't always
have to do it but it's good hygiene and
it just is it is a shoppings clarity of
your thinking right if you have a very
clear specification a problem and I
think when inside all of this is that if
your death set is really out of whack
right because it's so unbalanced that
accuracy your deficit doesn't translate
to what you actually care about because
you know presumably this is 99.5 percent
accurate on the deficit as well but this
performance is terrible so it's doing
great on the death set on your accuracy
nice shake we're giving terrible
performance so I think of it as good
hygiene you know this is kind of good
sound practice to just specify make sure
you at least have a Jeff said an
evaluation metric that corresponds more
closely to what you care about
so making the deaf set more balanced
equal numbers of positive and negative
which would be a good step toward that
and then I think what you could also
there are a few people that talked about
give the higher weights to the positive
examples right so you know one way to do
this is the resample your training and
your Jeff says to make them more
proportionate in terms of maybe closer
to balanced racial positive negative
examples that'd be okay the other way to
not do Reiss
we just give the positive examples it
great to wait right
I would probably sample another thing
you could do you know India in the
interests of speed even if it's not the
Matt Matthew most good most sound thing
to do is to change the target labels to
be a bunch of ones after that and this
is a hack this is not formally rigorous
but if you've implemented the rest of
this code already this might be a
reasonable you know a little bit hacky
thing to do but this is just this is
this might work well enough right I
would I might not I don't know if I
would want to try to you know write an
academic research paper with this method
maybe and get away with it but this
little thing that I think if you try to
publish your paper with this academic
review is my raising eyebrows and say
maybe now maybe it is okay but I think
if you're one something quick and dirty
that just works I think leaving the ones
changing back to labels to be one so
that say a clip here right oh that and
it's just a little bit off their proper
turn on the still label one that'd be
pretty reasonable it doesn't be saying
that for anywhere within maybe a 0.5
second period after Robert turn on
finish it's okay to turn on the light
any time within that period then you
kind of want to be turning on the light
turning on the lamp you know say within
half a second right after Robert turn on
this has been said anyway and this would
be a not this would be a way to just get
more labels of ones in there right how
does that translate to like when you
deploy this you're not gonna see Robert
turn on as much right like one out of
1,000 might be reflective of what you
expect to see
yeah yeah right so I think that uh
by the button so if you actually yes so
well I this is of a deaf set and
evaluation actually kind of question
right so one of the couple of the
metrics that people often use when
actually working on this is when someone
says Robert turned on what does the
chance that she wakes up or the lamp
turns on and then the second is if no
one is saying anything to the lamp you
know how often does it randomly turn on
by yourself without you having said
anything so those are the two metrics
people actually use and and sometimes
you could also try the combined in a
single number evaluation metric or
something but I think that you could
tend to find the data set to measure
both of these things and then and then
hopefully find a way to combine them
into single real number which I think
yeah and I think one of the ways you
talked about in the in the videos as
well great so make sense yeah but I
think I think the question is really Oh
what is it this satisfies a user need
right and Owen just want one thing about
dumb the straightforward way of
rebalancing is that if you don't do this
then your whole dataset just as very few
positive examples right and so if you
throw away all the negative examples so
that you cut down the number of negative
examples until you have exactly equal
numbers of positive and negatives you've
actually thrown away a lot of negative
examples this make sense and so one one
one problem with the straightforward way
of rebalancing is that you know in your
audio clip and your test ten-second clip
they were collected by running around
Stanford um you have one example of
Robert turn on and so if you want
exactly perfectly balanced positive
negative it means that you're allowed to
only clip on one negative example all of
this so you can say that's negative and
that's a positive
and you can't clip out more negative
examples from this right so so so if you
use a if you insist on the perfectly
balanced you're actually stirring away a
lot of negative examples that that could
be helpful for the learning all right
so alright so you know a lot of the
workflow of building learning algorithms
is building learning algorithms feels
more like debugging right because what
happens in a typical machine learning
workflow is you implement something and
it doesn't work so you figure out what
is the problem so you fix that like
rebalancing re-weighting we're adding
more ones and so that fixes the current
problem and then after fixing the
current problem which which is the one
we just solved say you then come across
a new problem and you have to solve that
and you fix that problem you cook
somewhere else another new problem so I
find it the workflow of when I'm working
a machine learning project it often
feels more like software debugging than
software development right because
you're often trying to figure out what
doesn't work and then trying to fix that
and after you fix that problem then
another bug surfaces and you squash that
and you do that and another and you kind
of keep doing that until the algorithm
work so if I keep talking about you know
your algorithm doesn't work what do you
do Nick right that's kind of theme of
today's presentation but that that is
what the workflow that is what your
day-to-day work of developing a learning
algorithm is usually like because I it
doesn't work you fix it it still doesn't
work as you fix that you still doesn't
worry you fix it and you do that enough
times until it works right that is
actually what often working on the
learning I don't work look looks like oh
all right
so let's say you fix that problem and
you conclude through doing error
analysis then your algorithm is
overfitting all right so you know you've
added a lot more ones so the data set is
a little bit more balanced so let's just
add a bunch of ones like I did on that
previous board where it was just out of
all the ones here so the data set isn't
as unbalanced and
let's see let's say that's sorry two
pages of notes here okay good
so let's say that um you find out that
the cheese now and I mean assign
accuracy on training and fifty percent
accuracy on the dev set right so very
large gap between your training and your
deaf set performance and so clear a sign
of overfitting and so I think one their
earlier question someone talked about
data augmentation and so when you have
this clear sign of overfitting this is a
good time to consider data augmentation
and then and so let's say you go ahead
and do JSOC mentation so for audio this
is how you could do data augmentation
which is um collect a bunch of
background audio you know so I guess if
you're trying to build a lamp that might
go into people's homes then you could go
into your friends homes and you know
with their permission record right what
the background sound in their home looks
like you know maybe uh people talk in
the background maybe the TV on the
background
well whatever goes on people's homes and
then it turns out that if you take a say
a one-second clip I've Robin turn on of
RTO and you add that to a background
clip then you can synthesize an audio
clip of what it sounds like and your
friend's house if someone were to
suddenly pop up and say Robert turn on
against the background sound of your
friend's house right and
and it turns out that if you want to
make the system robust so actually for
example I have a oh no I actually know
someone that lives unfortunately closely
to a train station and so their house
that she has a lot of train station
noise from the Caltrain and so what you
can do to make your system more robust
is also take you know a clip of say
train noise right like cow train noise
and if you take that noise and take a in
this case let's say one second one
second or three second clip of someone
saying robber turn on and you synthesize
that on top of the train in the
background then what you end up with is
a ten second clip of someone saying
robber turned on against the noisy you
know train in the background type of
pepper noise right and so in order to do
data augmentation or data synthesis you
can take some one second clip so people
say robber turn on in the quiet
background and then take some one second
clip but people saying random words
right let's say you know caught it all
all right it's a static and synthesized
this against the train noise background
and then you would have in this case you
would have what sounds like rain noise
train noise train on street noise
Robert turn on Trina Jana's or the
called in I was in a row right and then
you could generate the labels now as
girls there once there and then zeros
there because if this is what he sounded
like you know and I uses home then you
want the lamp to turn on after Robert
turn on but now after these random words
you can take different random words
great um so let's see right so
what I'd like you to do is evaluate
three different possible ways to collect
noisy data right two to collect this
type of background data right and so
what I'd like you to do for the next
question is let's say you and your team
you know have brainstormed brainstormed
a few different ways to collect this
type of background noise data and let's
say you've decided that you would like
to collect ten hours of background noise
data right okay so I'm gonna present to
you three options one is um you know run
around Stanford and replace microphones
around Stanford or your friends homes do
this with consent and don't don't you
know California you're not supposed to
don't record people about their
knowledge and consent right Oh
second is uh downloads clips online it
turns out you can go to youtube there
are these like ten hour long clips of
you know rain noise or cars driving
around so you actually can if you do
that find something that's creative
common sense of appropriately license
right um another thing you could do is
use a mechanical turk Amazon Mechanical
Turk we can have people all around the
world be paid you know modest amounts of
money to submit audio clips right so for
the next exercise what I want you to do
because I want you that this exercise
of this discipline which is what I want
you to do is um I went to the estimate
let's see what time is it
no okay it's 12:30 p.m. right now what I
want you to do is write down three
numbers in the next exercise to estimate
if you were to do this you know let's
say you were to go do this right now
right by what time will you have
finished it we went to do option one
what time would you finish you were to
do option two what time would you finish
you were to do option three if you go is
to collect ten hours of data through one
of these mechanisms that make sense so
it's 12:30 p.m. now so what I'd like you
to do is just write down three numbers
first number is what time is it what
time would be by the time you collected
ten hours of data you know from around
Stanford what time would be right and if
you could do this in some so if you
think you'd do it by tonight then right
9:00 p.m. if you think I'll do if you
think it'll take you one week then write
the date one week from now right
whatever it is but just write down three
numbers to these three activities okay
let's do this one relatively quickly can
people do this in like a maybe a minute
and a half
all right cool this is interesting
yeah what the people actually
surprisingly large variability I
mentioned one thing that surprised me
I'll give you my own assessment I think
that you know what I'm leading startup
teams we tend to be very scrappy right
and so I think that if it goes to
collect $10 of data if you have three
friends with laptop you can collect
three hours of data per hour because you
have three recordings going in parallel
so if I were doing this with say two
other friends you know I bet I bet we
could get this done by tonight great
because if you need nine hours of data
that's each person needs to collect
three hours of data and you run around
stand for the cue 2 microphones running
I bet I bet I could get this done by
6:00 p.m. right maybe maybe even earlier
I don't know
download clips online there's actually
no it's such an interesting one maybe a
bit about the same time it turns out one
tricky thing about downloading clips
online is that I think a lot of the you
know there are people that have trouble
sleeping at night so they listen to
highway noise or whatever and so there
are these you know 20 hours of highway
Clips highway noise on YouTube that you
can find but I I don't know how those
clips were generated and I suspect a lot
of them loop right meaning is the same
one hour play over and over so I
actually think is harder than then one
might guess to get 10 hours of
non-repetitive data and there's one of
those things you know if I take an hour
of how highway sound and loop it you
can't tell the difference because all
highway sounds sounds the same I just
can't tell one would have highway sound
from another one but if you have one
hour of highway sound looped ten times
the learning algorithm where she
performed much less well then if you
have ten hours of fresh highway sound so
this I would have a harder time doing I
think I probably I would proud if I were
doing this I because of these problems I
work very budget until sometime tomorrow
right maybe maybe 9:00 p.m. or something
maybe that's doable
I'm not sure um the one surprise to me
was some people thought they could do
this by tonight
I again I've used Amazon Mechanical Turk
is actually a huge process to set up and
some accounts are get people on board
and especially to get them microphone I
don't know if you implant something on
flash they can speak to their web
browser all and then factually
supportive is actually so it's actually
not that easy to get a lot of Turkish to
do this and the global supply of it's
also unlimited so I would if I were
doing this I would probably I know maybe
a week or something right hard to say
but so the specific opinion isn't that
important but I want you to go through
this exercise because this is how
efficient startup teams should you know
brainstorm a list of things and then you
all figure out how long you think it'll
take to do these things and I think we
can have a debate about how high quality
the dangerous I think you can get very
high quality data from this and from
this I I just didn't trust a lot of
those online audio sources but this is
really fast and you can get pretty high
quality data I would probably do this to
collect the background sound to get
going right but I think that part of the
workflow I see of you know fast moving
teams is pretty much exactly what you
did which is why I just have that
exercise of brainstorming the list of
options and then really estimating what
time can we get this done and then use
that to pick an option right um
and then I wanna just mention one last
thing which is that
these differences matter right um you
know I've actually a Pulaski system for
long machinery systems but oh and I
think by the way if you do everything we
just described and you see this later
in a problem set you can actually with
this set of ideas pretty much the set of
ideas that we just went through today
you can actually probably build and
build a pretty decent trigger where
detection system or way question or
detection system and in fact well I'll
see that you're pretty much this in the
later homework exercise but now you know
when you get to that power exercise when
you do are an ends up you know how you
could come up with this sort of process
yourself if you didn't already know how
to make these types of choices affect my
results by the way the beginning I think
that it's not super sense which like
many micro moments or lights is the same
as the one that's used when I run the
run standpoint that's what I don't keep
with my best but my data points you have
to yeah so my advice ed what does your
microphone affect your results right
yeah my advice it would be to get
something going quickens are here and
then develop a dev set right with the
actual types of data you think you get
on your real microphone and then see if
it is a problem and it may be in
different microphones do have different
characteristics and if it is a problem
then go back and think about how you
collect data there's more representative
upon you yes I want to mention one more
quick thing there were kind of hot
surveys I wanted to do something real
quick
which is um I want to tell you why these
things really matter which is um if this
is a performance right unless they
actually missing error
and this is tiny right and if this is
today and the other see all this data
remember yes that's what we're doing
just Lessing and this is six months from
now and this is 12 months but now you
know maybe of a competitor actually
maybe maybe I don't know maybe a because
we talked about this so much in this
class it may be two of you in this
posture gonna build this sauce up but I
said it may be a competitor um
but over time mostly machine learning
teams you know the error actually goes
down over time as you work on problems
right I mean this is what I see in tons
of practical projects you know you work
on the project improve the system and
the error actually goes down over time
as you work on this over the next 12
months a right if you really see over
started doing this and it turns out that
it's a start up to have the discipline
to constantly be the most efficient
don't do something that takes you two
days if you can get a similar result in
one day
the difference is not that you're one
day slower the difference is that you're
2x faster right and then then having
that mindset if we take this whole chart
and compress it on the horizontal axis
um then you want to be the startup that
you know makes the same amount of
progress in six months instead of 12
months variant because if you're able to
do this then your startup will actually
perform much better in the marketplace
assuming your accuracy is important
which it seems to be for wake where it
and so don't think of this as saving you
a day here and there think of this as
making your team twice as fast and
that's the difference between this level
of performance and downloadable so
that's why when I'm you know building
teams executing these projects I tend to
be pretty obsessive about making sure
we're very efficient in exploring the
options and don't wait till tomorrow to
collect data of dubious quality when you
have a better idea of collecting data by
today because the difference is not that
you wasted 12 hours the difference is
you had twice as slow as a company right
so I think so hopefully through this
example on your ongoing experiences
throughout this course I can help you
continue
to get better at this right um
last thing we want to do was we're about
halfway through the course I'll go ahead
um we want to hand out a survey of an
anonymous survey to get some feedback
from you about this class and whenever
we get these surveys we end up thanks to
the previous generations of students
feedback we've already been gradually
making cause better so I think Ken and I
actually read all of these questions
ourselves and try to find ways to take
your feedback to improve the class so I
can take you know five minutes to felt
the survey and you can hand it in just
drop it up anonymously up here in front
but very grateful for your suggestions
okay so um I think if you haven't
entered your ID yet you can still do so
but that's it for today so please start
the survey and anonymously drop that
back in front then we wrap okay thank
you